well you know it becomes quite wearying
to hear about atrocities like this but
the worst thing we could do is get bored
of it and just stop paying attention so
we begin with footage of another all
ages drag show quote unquote in Texas
attended and documented by Sarah
Gonzalez of the blaze she says that she
has more footage on the way but the
30-second clip that she posted yesterday
is shocking enough on its own it shows a
man in drag lifting up his skirt and
gyrating around while people throw money
at him and in the background you can see
a child who can't be more than I don't
know six or seven years old
looking on confused and obviously
completely Disturbed meanwhile the music
which is blasting through the restaurant
is
so vulgar and sexual that I can't play
the the clip with sound and I can't even
quote the lyrics to All I can say is
that it's a woman wrapping an extremely
graphic terms about her genitals and
about the various sex acts that she
wants to perform
so there's at least one child in the
building
listening to that while watching a
cross-dressing man dance around with his
skirt pulled up to reveal the women's
underwear underneath
and this is happening in Texas
I feel like we can't emphasize that
enough that so many of these things so
much so much of this footage that we're
getting it's from Texas
it's this bad in Texas so we can be sure
that it's even worse pretty much
everywhere else in the country
especially in a place like Oregon where
as Andy know reports for the
post-millennial a bar is uh planning a
drag show this coming weekend featuring
an 11 year old performer and it gets
worse read it from the article it says
controversy has erupted after a pub in
Eugene Oregon announced it is hosting a
drag queen event featuring an 11 year
old child an investigation by the
post-millennial has revealed that one of
the child's drag Moms quote unquote was
recently charged with child sex abuse
offenses
uh quote are you excited for drag queen
Story Time brunch this Sunday morning
old Nick's Pub asked in a Facebook
announcement Vanellope is here to show
you what a what an 11 year old drag
queen can do
the post featured several photos of
Vanellope craving McPherson
Vanellope craving McPherson Dupont
that's the stage name of the child
including one where she is touching her
chest and her mouth is open the
postmodial is not publishing the real
name of the child old Nick's Pub is
known locally in the University Town for
being a leftist bar and it frequently
hosts drag shows as well as sexual
fetish events Vanellope has performed at
different events around the state of
Oregon sometimes with grown male
performers and risque outfits since at
least 2018. the girl has cash app and
venmo accounts where adults often send
her cash tips
photographs on our Facebook page also
show her being showered on stage with
dollar bills
by the way as you may note there this
article and others that I've read about
this uh refer to the child as her but if
this is a drag queen then you'd think
that means the child is actually a boy
unless they've now started dressing
little girls up like drag queens too
which maybe they have I'm not sure
what's the case here but either way
whether a girl or a boy
drag is an inherently sexualized
burlesque performance and there is no
Universe in which it would be acceptable
to include children either male or
female in such a spectacle in any
capacity whether as Spectators or
especially as performers
continuing on it says vanellope's
Handler
Jennifer Hibbs is also her drag mom
she uses a stage name Sunshine Ray
McPherson and is a longtime lgbtq
activist Hibbs clarified she is not the
girl's parent or Guardian as previously
reported but is the Handler for the
child
quote her actual mother does her
choreography so that it's all
appropriate him said we wouldn't let her
do anything suggest suggestive it's
terrible that people assume that we
would let her do that
we're the terrible ones you see not the
adults who are sexualizing and taking
advantage of a child we're the terrible
ones it's our assumptions that are
terrible
but here's another important detail from
those reported says on August 11th
vanellope's other long-term drag mom
Kelsey M Boren who uses the stage name
always craving was arrested in Lane
County and charged with 12 felonies
related to making and distributing child
porn brought prosecutors found the 32
year old such a danger to the public
that they successfully petitioned the
judge to deny her bail at the time of
her arrest Boren was a teaching
assistant for a special education
student at vannetta Elementary in
vanilla Vanetta Oregon
she allegedly told detectives that her
need for child porn was like a quote
uncontrollable itch that she couldn't
stop
now
a few things here are confusing well
more than a few things but focusing just
on on these for a moment for one thing
the pronoun situation is all over the
map okay it's not clear of the various
people mentioned here which are actually
females though they all use female
pronouns I mean it doesn't really make a
difference I suppose the child is being
exploited either way the adults are
creeps and degenerates and worse either
way
um but that is a confusing aspect of
this also I was not previously familiar
with the term drag mom
though from Context it seems that this
is just another way of describing a
professional groomer
the uh quote drag child is handed over
to the drag mom to be groomed and
conditioned it seems to be essentially a
sort of pedophilic predatory farm system
that the groomers have set up
so
what can be done about this that's
really the question
we've established that this is happening
and it's only getting worse over time
progressivism does what the name
suggests what the label suggests it's
progressivism so it progresses except
that it progresses in the same sense
that say cancer progresses it keeps
spreading and getting worse and eating
away at our civilization until it is
stopped
or until it destroys its host
and just like cancer stopping it
is not a gentle or a painless process
the farther along the cancer is the more
aggressive you have to be in fighting it
culturally we are approaching if we
haven't already reached a terminal state
which means we have to be all the more
aggressive which calls for two things
first
obviously
involving children in drag events in any
capacity
should be outright criminalized
everywhere there is no other way you
know this doesn't stop until police are
breaking down the doors at these places
and carting the adults away in handcuffs
charge them all as pedophiles throw them
in prison and and whenever they get out
if they do get out put them on the sex
offender registry for life
that man in the first clip dancing
around with his skirt up
should be treated legally as a child
predator
that that's the level of protection that
our children are owed and the people
sexualizing exploiting them are owed
that level of punishment
this is something that needs to start in
red States and if Republicans take over
the White House it should be handled on
the federal level as well I know that um
that republicans in Congress have just
put out a bill that would uh that calls
for the defunding uh you know that
forbids the federal government from
funding or facilitating
the sexualization of children in any
form and that includes you know sexually
explicit material being handed out in
schools that includes drag queen you
know uh drag queen story hours and all
the rest of it
and that's good because certainly we
should not be funding or in any way
facilitating any of that
but we've got to go far beyond that
you know this should all be criminalized
second we don't have to wait for
lawmakers to get their act together
we can act by heaping shame and Scorn on
the adults responsible for this public
shame is an indispensable tool it's one
necessary for a civilized society to
function
but it's one that we have you know
historically become quite shy about
using and when I say we I don't mean the
left because the left they're not shy
about it they'll shame their enemies
without hesitation they'll destroy your
your life and your reputation if they
can so public shame is is their number
one tool it's their most it's their
favorite tool to use
the difference is that they are most
often heaping shame on people who don't
deserve it and they're doing it as a
means of avoiding intellectual
engagement
we on the other hand should be making
social pariahs out of people whose
Behavior warrants it
because we have tolerated far too much
the very people who are the quickest to
wield shame as a weapon
somehow convinced us that we shouldn't
use it ever
oh it's wrong to shame people you can't
shame people
they say well they go around shaming
everyone
the effect is a culture where people can
do the most shameful things without any
shame at all notice how all these places
they you know they they advertise their
child drag queen shows and they're all
Quote all ages drag shows and all the
rest of it and it's the same story over
and over again they advertise it they
put the Flyers out they put the stuff up
on Facebook they they oftentimes will
post their own videos of these things
and then they start scrambling and
panicking when the backlash comes
now you might think well that's that's
an act they're they're pretending but I
don't think it is an act
they sincerely did not expect any public
outrage because they've been able to do
what they whatever they want for so long
without anyone criticizing them for it
so they assume that that would continue
they have gotten comfortable
far far too comfortable
I would say
and now it's up to us to make them
uncomfortable
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block
thanks for watching have a great day
Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]